she was just perfect feisty funny like
good situation I have anything bad she'd
always make you laugh as well nine
months ago Dan Watts sister Becky was
murdered her body dismembered the 16
year old was suffocated in her Bristol
home by their stepbrother nathan
Matthews he's now serving a life
sentence
his girlfriend Shawn a [ __ ] has been
jailed for manslaughter this would be
when she got past their fairies and God
their confidence in herself in his first
ever interview Dan Watts told Sky News
he believes Matthews is too dangerous
to ever be released what's your reaction
to the prison sentences that they got
life with him but minimum 33 years 17
years for sure still not enough room for
her do you think he should ever be
released from prison
no why not because he won't be safe
right I mean teenagers or anyone there
be 61 regrets how and they're still be
looking for teenagers because it's gone
in that in police interviews Matthews
always claimed Becky's death was an
accident in reality he and his
girlfriend were planning to kidnap her
first sex due to a fixation with
teenagers
Becky was killed on her brother Dan's
20th birthday
what is that day signify for you now
what does that mean no idea people say
buddy you can there like it darling I've
always University my sister was taken
will you ever be able to mark that day
again don't
see her just like pay tribute to my
sister or party twice as hard for her so
once a key member of this family
Nathan grew up with Becky and Dan the
big brother they never had but he robbed
this teenager of life then took her
dignity and death and those crimes will
never be forgiven just complete animal
because he never sued I saw it to me
when I was younger just the trail from
him is unbelievable what for you would
mean justice for Becky him did for him
in a room of laorfamily and what
happened she born robin's Sky News in
Bristol